you're watching the daily climate show
on sky news coming up
the floods which killed more than 400
south africans last month were made
twice as likely and more intense by
global warming
extreme weather in australia this just
as elections approach with climate
change on the agenda
and tidal power why aren't we making the
most of seas around britain to create
clean energy
[Music]
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show where we track the
changes happening to our world hear from
the people being hit hardest by those
changes and reports on the race for
solutions now we start this evening with
a vivid reminder of how climate change
is affecting the most vulnerable people
in the world the extreme rainfall which
is caused devastating flooding in south
africa last month was made twice as
likely and more intense by climate
change according to climate scientists
now hundreds of people were killed when
the rain swept through the area around
durban south africa's busiest port well
first let's have a reminder of what
happened from our africa correspondent
john sparks
the province of purzulu natal was hit by
floods which produced one of the worst
natural disasters this country has seen
in years
a really traumatic event it claimed the
lives of at least 440 people and it was
enhanced or supercharged by climate
change this according to leading
scientists who warn that weather events
like this will become more frequent with
more severe consequences when they
strike
two days of torrential rain caused
flooding and mudslides that destroyed 4
000 homes housing an estimated 40 000
people
dozens are still missing
key infrastructure like roads and
bridges were wiped out but many of those
who suffered lived in settlements that
didn't benefit from anything like that
their communities didn't have municipal
drainage systems for example and they
lived in homes or shacks that were
unable to withstand the intensity of the
rain
and of course this is another
consequence of climate change the
poorest and most vulnerable suffer
disproportionately
residents in kwazulu natal reported
seeing adults and children being swept
away by rivers that have been turned
into raging torrents
this catastrophe will prove a massive
political challenge for the governing
anc which has declared it a national
disaster and its promise to rebuild
people's homes and the infrastructure
but the party is mired in allegations of
corruption and incompetence and many
residents say they'll have to sort
things out themselves
well joining me now is professor
frederica otto climate scientist with
the grantham institute at imperial
college and co-founder of the world
weather attribution group who carried
out this research uh friederika thank
you so much for joining us this evening
can you just tell me what surprised you
most about your research here
to be honest i don't think there was
there was anything very surprising in in
this particular study that we carried
out because um as uh as your colleague
has said it was uh extremely high
rainfalls um that uh particularly uh hit
informal settlements and poorer
communities and municipalities hard
which is what we see the world around
when extreme weather
when extreme weather event strikes and
also
we are expecting in a warmer world to
see that heavy rainfall events
especially on short time scales so daily
or two days as in this case um that they
are becoming more intense and more
frequent because of climate change and
um our study has has shown that this was
indeed the case uh for for this
particular event that hit quasar natal
and and the surrounding eastern um south
african provinces
and we know that the science has come a
long way
quite fast how can you be so definitive
about the research and the findings that
you have
because everything um
everything fits together so we have
observational data and uh
there are quite a lot of
weather observation stations in south
africa um they are threatened um
by by lack of funding so some of them
had to stop recording weather but there
is still a lot of weather data so we
have a quite a good picture of how
um rainfall has been changing over the
last years we have climate models that
are able to simulate the kind of weather
systems that led to this event so it was
a cut off a so-called cutoff low which
is a low pressure system that brings in
this this this rainfall and also
the basic physics of a warming world
also tell us that
a warmer atmosphere can hold more water
vapor and that needs to get out of the
atmosphere and it does so as heavy
rainfall so we have
several independent lines of evidence
that all show the same thing
that this type of extreme event is
getting more frequent and more intense
because of man-made climate change and
so in this case it's a doubling of the
likelihood of such an event to occur
and how are you going to use this
research to to find solutions to come up
with ways of helping communities because
as you we we know it's the poorest that
are affected the most
yes so it it is really what um
there is well there is no such thing as
a natural disaster um
but what turns a natural hazard or in
this case and not quite so natural
hazard but a hazard that has been
enhanced because of climate change into
a disaster is
vulnerability and exposure and so in
this case it's really the structural
vulnerability that is a legacy of the
apartheid
regime and also the rapid urban growth
that that that led to the problems but
there is um so durbin is one of the
regions in south africa that has really
a high awareness of the threats of
climate change and they have
plans climate adaptation plans they
haven't been implemented yet
and
but they have plans and these plans are
actually really good
so
we hope
that this study can show
that it's really just making the plans
alone is isn't isn't going to save any
lives but they have to be implemented
and they have to be implemented fast but
these plans already exist in durban so
um the the municipality is way ahead for
many other parts of the world and could
actually really become a leader in
climate adaptation and and um we really
hope that that this
will help um to make that happen so that
not more events like this um
will will have so disastrous effect okay
frederica thank you very much for your
time
well let's take a look at some of the
day's other climate news now and the
business secretary has warned that plans
to build new nuclear power plants may
initially
increase energy bills as the government
seeks to end reliance on russian oil and
gas and move towards low carbon energy
sources qazi qatan's comments came as
the government announced a new 120
million pound future
nuclear-enabling fund to provide
targeted grants for nuclear construction
projects nuclear power is a big part of
the government's energy strategy
announced in april
in queensland police have rescued two
men and three dogs from a van caught by
flood water as hundreds of residents
were ordered to evacuate their homes for
the second time in months officials have
warned that further heavy rainfall could
lead to life-threatening flash floods
and potential landslides recently
australia has suffered severe droughts
bush fires and mass bleaching on the
great barrier reef making climate change
a very key issue for voters at the
country's federal elections next week
temperatures in pakistan have reached
almost 50 degrees celsius as officials
in the country warn of water shortages
and a threat to health so since march
much of pakistan and india have been
experiencing a heat wave and experts
warn this is consistent with climate
change pakistan home to 220 million
people says it is responsible for less
than one percent of global greenhouse
gas emissions
now while renewable energy wind and
solar make up um an ever-growing chunk
of our electricity tidal power is as yet
nowhere to be seen
with such a vast coastline the question
is why not and there are now lots of
projects underway
and today saw the opening of a new
testing facility in scotland and
fastblade will test tidal turbine blades
with researchers say can speed up the
development of this technology
well joining me now is the head of
edinburgh university's school of
engineering professor cooher o'brodie um
thank you so much for joining us just
give us a little insight into the type
of technology you have developed
yes our role is to carry out research
and to support the engineering companies
that are developing these
um
types of tidal turbine
installations which are now being
developed to megawatt scale particularly
in scotland but around the english coast
as well
and how much of a difference do you
think it can make because it is quite
costly
yeah it's costly at present because
there are very there are only about six
megawatts of tidal energy installed
but the government's um
allocation round ar4
will provide support for further 34
megawatts of tidal energy
and the type of resource that's
available around the uk coastline is
about six gigawatts which would equate
to about 11 percent of the country's
electricity so just like wind energy as
the number of installations increase
the cost of the energy will drop quite
fast and why do you think it hasn't been
utilized up until now is it just a that
complicated mix of
cost
i i think it's it's an issue of cost
it's also an issue of the correct
technology being available
there have been great strides made made
in the last few years in terms of
developing
more uh cost-effective and more
accessible for operations and
maintenance etc for instance the
development of floating tidal turbines
which are being pioneered in the
european marine energy center in arkley
orkney in scotland
and the missing piece for the industry
is the ability to rapidly test and
certify the fiber reinforced composite
blades that are used as the prime movers
in the tidal turbines and that's what
the fastblade facility at the university
of edinburgh funded by the apsrc and in
partnership with babcock will provide
okay professor o'brodie thank you very
much for joining us today
or do stay with us coming up
can we decarbonize the grid in the next
few years i'll be joined by heather
plumpton policy analyst at green
alliance and akshay garathi senior
climate reporter at bloomberg news to
discuss all of that and a bit more
[Music]
it's a secret society having anxiety
uh people are incredibly good at masking
it and some of the most confident people
can't i've had to stop myself from
saying to someone while i've been doing
my book tour
you don't seem like you're anxious
because the most confident looking
people can put on the front and
underneath they are monstered by anxiety
i'd say with any
uh anxiety treatment we're looking a lot
of the time we're looking for like the
perfect treatment you know the one
that's definitely gonna a lot of people
ask me what's the one treatment that's
gonna work um with any treatment for any
kind of mental health issue you're
looking at a balance of probabilities
and i'd say there's no one treatment
that works for everyone for me
personally
uh i really struggled with some of the
basic ones that are the best evidenced
like uh
medication and uh therapy they haven't
worked for me and that's true for about
25 of the population will find that
medication
and cbt which are offered on the nhs
neither of those work for them so in
those cases uh you have to look a little
bit further afield and that's where
things like
you know maybe ice baths
although they seem a little bit maybe uh
extreme they can come into it so i did
lots of things i did some of the things
that you would have heard a lot when you
read articles about it so
exercise uh changing my diet
um
cold water swimming and ice baths uh i
was interested i did some hypnotherapy
uh i
i tried all those kind of things i mean
the iceberg um
i have to say you know there is some
reasonably good uh beginning research on
it and how it might affect the immune
system that kind of fight flight or
freeze response is triggered when you
get into freezing water your body starts
pumping out adrenaline and cortisol
because your body is thinking that
there's a threat and it wants to get you
out of there quickly
and if you're anxious
that whole system is dysregulated in you
and by slowly getting used to
being in a situation where your body
pumps out adrenaline pumps out cortisol
and learning how to breathe calmly in
that situation
it can be look i'm not it is horrible
when i'm shivering in my picture i'm
having a horrible time in the moment
but afterwards
oh my goodness i felt wonderful
hello and welcome back to the daily
climate show on sky news well let's
discuss some of the issues raised
earlier with heather plumpton from green
alliance and actually
a climate journalist from bloomberg news
thank you both for joining us this
evening we really appreciate it so the
big question i want to kick off with is
there's more clear evidence today isn't
there that climate change is
contributing to extreme weather events
now more than 400 people were killed in
floods in south africa last month and
with the world's attention on ukraine
outside of south africa the event passed
with
little comment um
we know that climate change does affect
the poorest people in those communities
they're more vulnerable to climate
change
and that's what's happened here
where people lived in informal settings
and this continues to happen around the
world doesn't it
it does i mean another event that we've
talked about in recent months is the
extreme weather when the heat event
that's happening in south asia across
pakistan india bangladesh nepal
and
it is the poorest people who are being
affected because they are the people who
can't afford air conditioning they are
the people who can't afford access to
clean drinking water uh or to homes that
are protected from this kind of heat um
and we are going to face more of these
challenges uh in the coming years and
decades um and it's going to increase
the clamor that uh developing countries
have been making uh for rich countries
to pay up for the loss and damage that
is going to come their way because of
all the accumulated greenhouse gas
emissions that have been put into the
atmosphere by those countries
and i suppose heather the the point that
oxshot makes there is that adaptation
in the face of climate crisis is really
important because it will be the
rickshaw drivers in india that will have
to deal with this sweltering heat all
the people in south africa who lost
their homes because they're not built in
the correct way adaptation is key
heather
yes absolutely adaptation is key and the
uk can play a really
it should be playing a really strong
role here we actually still
have the presidency of 26 which was the
big climate conference in glasgow the uk
still holds that presidency for the rest
of the year so they really do need to be
playing a key leadership role in
bringing together countries to deliver
that finance to address the losses and
damages that countries are facing
due to climate change but they also need
to be looking at what they're doing on
the home front i mean the uk needs to
also walk the walk at home on adaptation
you just have to look at the newspapers
over the last week or so in the uk with
the hot weather we've been having and
posted alongside a picture of someone
having a day out at the beach
um and now obviously this is nowhere
near as extreme as what's happening in
south asia
but we know that heat waves can be
really damaging to people's health
especially the old or the unwell and the
uk's building stock is not ready to
handle this change let alone food
production and the latest assessment
from the climate change committee says
it's actually getting worse in the uk
the gap between the policy we have on
adaptation and the risk we face is
getting bigger so we really do need to
make sure that we're designing policies
in the uk that provide both adaptation
and carbon reduction it's interesting
you say that heather because what these
ex
incidents show us whether it's in dubai
in south africa or in calcutta in india
is that climate change affects everyone
there's no kind of discrimination when
it comes to climate change uh upshot
that's right and uh we're going to see i
mean uh the events that play out
differently because of uh the way
weather plays out differently but in the
regions that it will it will feel more
extreme uh than it was in in the past
and i mean the the heat wave in india
for example uh
over the past few decades we've seen the
number of deaths that heat waves have
caused
go down because india has taken some
steps towards adaptation uh towards
creating a plan around these heat waves
but
we also have a problem in india where
they don't always count the people who
suffer or who die from these kinds of
events properly and so we also have a
data problem where if you don't count
these debts and you're not able to
associate it with uh the the extreme
weather event then you won't be able to
act uh and adapt or help people adapt to
what is uh going to be a worse event
coming in the near next decades indeed
really interesting and i think it leads
us on to our next uh a big story here
that i want to talk about to you both
and we're talking about renewables now
because um our electricity agreed is
being powered by renewables in a big way
today
and today we know it's running at almost
60 renewables and the prime minister
has said that he wants it a hundred
percent um by
2035. um so what has to change to make
that possible how do we decarbonize how
we 100 green by
2035 heather
so there's lots of the government could
be getting on with in terms of no
regrets of options that need to be
rolled out quickly um building more
renewables of which there is a lot
already in the pipeline getting you know
getting ready to go the investments
there from the companies but we need to
speed up that roll out through reforms
to things like planning rules so the
onshore wind which is actually you know
the cheapest
it's quick and actually very popular
with the public so that can be built at
speed
and similarly for offshore wind
we need to make sure they can connect to
the electricity grid quickly so
currently it can take up to 10 years to
get a connection to the grid so the
government needs to be looking at ways
of regulations for the electricity
network to make sure the grid is ready
to take on all of these new renewables
into the system
sorry heather sorry heather so actually
there are lots of um projects in the
pipeline from what heather's saying uh
but
it's not rolled out yet tell us a bit
about what potential we have here in the
uk
so yeah heather's absolutely right uh
the first step towards getting to a
hundred percent uh clean grid is to roll
out more of the renewables that we do
know uh onshore in offshore rain solar
but
as we get closer to getting to 100 clean
uh we will uh face difficulties with
these renewables where there'll be
intermittency issues and you're going to
have to deal with uh periods when for a
week or two weeks there's not enough
wind and you need to fill those with
clean sources either those are sources
like tidal power
which are currently at a very nasal
stage but could play a bigger role or
geothermal power which there's some
resource available uh you know maybe if
not in the uk then to import it from
other places um or you use batteries uh
in initially we use lithium-ion
batteries these are the same batteries
that power electric cars but eventually
you're going to need batteries that can
last hundreds of hours there's a company
in the us called form energy which does
something very innovative where it takes
iron converts it into rust
creates electricity in that process and
then to store electricity in it it
converts that rust back into iron and
simplifying a little bit but really uh
not that much the the chemistry is
actually quite that simple
and these kinds of technologies will
have to be developed if we are to uh to
reach the 100 uh clean grid and and and
so soon which is in 2035.
fascinating ideas there
heather i i wonder in terms of
individual households you know but that
people at home will be watching this and
and tidal energy and battery storage all
fantastic ideas but what can you do from
a personal perspective to help this
target of clean energy by 2035
well all of this would be much easier if
we actually needed less power in the
first place so the big kind of missing
piece in terms of the government
strategy that will impact on people's
homes and households is energy
efficiency so we actually have some of
the leakiest housing in europe in the uk
we're literally letting glass gas sorry
just blow out the leaky window
so the government really does need to
step up with an ambitious well-funded
program to help people who want to
insulate their homes you know it's it's
a no-brainer for reducing household
bills that was facing a cost of living
crisis at the moment um largely due to
fossil fuel energy prices
so the the most important thing that the
government could be doing right now
is actually funding a program to help
people who who can't necessarily afford
to insulate their homes themselves to do
that
okay heather akshat thank you very much
for joining us today fascinating to talk
to you both and don't forget that the
latest edition of climatecast is now
available this week i spoke to climate
activists about the role of protests in
climate action this after the government
announced a clampdown on what they call
disruptive protests and you can scan the
qr code on the screen or download from
wherever you find your podcast
well that's it for this week thanks so
much for joining us we'll be back on
monday bye bye for now
[Music]